have another champion the k3 state
champion a guy who's made so many people
proud and inspired so many over the last
couple weeks as his story went viral
tani IV Rumi is with Maurice it's indeed
young tiny winning that New York state
primary division at the age of eight
most were inspired however by the fact
that his family was a refugee family and
living in a homeless shelter but talent
Springs everywhere tani welcome to the
show how you feeling now you you're in
st. Louis with the best players in the
country what does it feel like tell me
who your favorite players are I heard
that you had some players first of all
who's your top favorite player
my coach which coach coach Shaw knows
number two number two is got Daniel top
says okay and who's number three a
director called trust
I heard them before Fabiano comes in
fourth on that list all right I'm sure
father will be pleased to hear that and
their Nakamura okay and then me number
six
I'll take it I'll take it that's cool I
know you came in yesterday looking to
play against us you yet you're chess it
already well you disappointed that you
didn't beat up on the grandmasters why
not because
like I laugh I lost you lost you lost
good attitude good attitude tell me the
New York state championship what did it
mean to you the win that's one of it
feels awesome did you have it you have
any bigger aspirations than that like do
you have any bigger goals in life than
just winning the New York like what's
your next big goal in winning the New
York state championship my next goal
yeah your next big goal like do you have
any other things you want to do
so when Nationals win the Nationals
Nationals are coming up yeah where are
they I mean in Nashville cool and then
what then dad and I want to be the
younger grandma
the youngest Grand Master in history now
who is the youngest Grand Master in
history
taiyaki how old was he when he became a
Grand Master 12 years older 7 12 and 7
months you got the number down and
you're 8 and how many months right now
eight and six or seven probably all
right when's your birthday
third September so you've got four years
to catch car yakin do you think you
could do it yeah what makes you so sure
confident confidence I hear that now I
saw you with a little toy where'd you
get this picked that up and show the
show the folks where did you get that
from
I got a problem that I'm across the
world has Hall of Fame mm-hmm okay
well cute boutique the shop is at their
world that's all the fame and you got a
chance to walk through the Hall of Fame
today what was that like did you did you
like the experience yeah now we see
there we see you on screen playing some
shows that you're playing click angle
good angel who wins when you guys play
hmm who wins when you to play you don't
know I I messed up
we're not playing him in my last game of
play that I messed up okay we see you
there
what did you like about this Hall of
Fame with all the great greatest players
in history what was your favorite thing
about this experience
I played the grandmasters
he's the all of our players mom and dad
your mom and dad support you yes what
about kids at school how do they feel
about the success you've had okay they
also support me kept a lot of support
coming in man yeah well we're all very
proud of you for everything you've done
how long do you think it's gonna take
first of all do you want to play in this
sort of make one day the national
championship yes how many things don't
take you to get here okay yeah mm-hmm I
would say maybe in two years or three
years two or three years to play in the
national consciousness or cherishes you
got a UH you got a lot of ambition young
man we also know that you had a GoFundMe
campaign that raised over a quarter
million dollars for those of you who
would like to donate to that campaign
which helps not only itani with his
family but also homeless kids homeless
people all around the country which the
family has generously donated to you can
go to their GoFundMe page I believe we
have that for you on screen or or you
can at least look it up and look up
tondee's name and you'll find it for
sure
taani we appreciate you we appreciate
everything you've done and I guess was
good luck first of all in the Nationals
and I guess we'll see you in 2 or 3
years thank you young man
ok yesterday you played all the
grandmasters you played fabbi and
Kristin Christian I was gonna say who
did you like best which game who did you
like playing against best yeah what did
I like clinic wrecks hey honey I saw you
over looking at all the games um what do
you think is gonna happen today in the
big Nakamura battle against Dominguez it
looks like white has more space why does
has more space black is trying to get in
the center attack well Nakamura
still holding up the position like the
position now we have here and I think he
has some attacks in the cup for dextrose
do you think dr. murrow's gonna get it
done yeah Wow this kid might even steal
one of our jobs just slow down Thank You
Johnny and much success in your goals
your career goals yes it was just
wonderful to have it is wonderful to
have tani here in st. Louis
he's just so inspiring I know so many
people who want a chance to meet him to
make an impact one of the really
inspiring parts of the story is that
they raised so much money on go fund me
that family set up a foundation vitani a
true me foundation to help funnel
donations to other kids in need
especially from the African community
and African refugees not just from
Nigeria where his family is from but
other countries as well and I think in
particularly in New York right well
yesterday he was collecting on his chess
board the signatures of all the
grandmasters I was thinking I should
have brought a chess board and said
Tommy could you say amazing I mean so
talented but also in the New York Times
article and Nicholas Kristof wrote that
opportunity is limited but talent is
universal but what I got from the
evening is that what's even more
important than resources is love and
support and that's really what tani has
in spades I mean is his family your
family and his coaches are just so
loving and supportive yeah it really
just goes to show how unquantifiable
that is not something you can put a
dollar price on No